on this Monday night new rules at
Canada's border who's now banned and why
Americans are still allowed now is the
time to take this particular step as the
kovat 19 crisis escalates the message to
Canadian travelers if you're abroad it's
time for you to come home plus the
markets take again and from
self-isolation to testing for the new
coronavirus we get answers from the
experts
global national would gonna freezing
tonight
Robin Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
after weeks of growing pressure and with
cases rising rapidly the Canadian
government is taking steps to secure the
border Ottawa is borrowing most
foreigners except Americans from
entering Canada and only for Canadian
airports will be allowed to accept
international flights and now is the
time to take this particular step it is
a significant step it is a step that we
take in exceptional circumstances but it
is the right step to be taking today as
part of the new restrictions the Prime
Minister says any Canadians who are
abroad and have kovat 19 symptoms will
not be allowed to board flights home
he's urging people to do their part to
help slow the spread let me be clear if
you're abroad it's time for you to come
home if you've just arrived
you must self isolate for 14 days and
finally all Canadians as much as
possible should stay home the situation
in Canada is changing quickly here's
what we can tell you as of right now
there are more than four hundred and ten
cases across the country BC Ontario and
Quebec all recorded double-digit
increases today and the number of deaths
has jumped from one to four after three
more people died in BC they're all
linked to a North Vancouver care home
the situation in the US and Europe is
escalating we'll get to that in just a
moment but first what's happening here
at home as the government ramps up its
response to the outbreak Mike Armstrong
has tonight's top story
stepping out of Rideau cottage where
he's insult isolation with his family
the Prime Minister basically closed the
country to most of the world Canadians
will still be allowed to return home
citizens and permanent residents but
starting Wednesday Canada will be
denying entry to most foreign nationals
there are exceptions for people like
airline crews and diplomats but also one
very big group US citizens despite an
increase in cases south of the border
the Prime Minister isn't cutting off
access to Americans for now we recognize
that the level of integration of our two
economies and the coordination that we
have we've had over the past while puts
the u.s. in a separate category from the
rest of the world but we will continue
to coordinate with the US we will
continue to examine next steps and
measures that must be taken now getting
on planes to come home to Canada will
also get tougher airlines are being
ordered to refuse access to anyone with
symptoms things like a cough or a fever
any passenger regardless of citizenship
with possible kovat 19 symptoms will not
be allowed to board flights to Canada
there are changes coming to where planes
arrive back in Canada
most international flights are going to
be funneled to four airports Montreal
Toronto Calgary and Vancouver there are
exceptions flights from the US Mexico
and the Caribbean are not affected but
again with that disclaimer for now
Ottawa is making it very clear things
could get even tighter at any time well
good morning everyone and now ottawa's
reaction at the border comes after some
criticism there's been pressure from
several premiers that the federal
government wasn't taking the threat from
international travelers seriously enough
the frustration was so strong in Quebec
that the city of Montreal sent public
health officials to the airport to
remind travelers daesh itself isolate
for 14 days now there is new increased
screening at airports international
travelers are having to answer questions
on CBS a kiosk touchscreens they have to
say whether they have symptoms and
acknowledge they know they have to self
isolate for two weeks for the first time
there are new
extra border guards at airports looking
for travelers with symptoms that
something critics have been calling for
for days border guards are also being
given masks to hand out when they're
concerned with someone's health Robin
Mike Armstrong in Ottawa thanks Mike
Canada's chief medical health officer
says the new travel restrictions are
needed to try to slow the spread of
Cobra 19 but one big question why are
Americans exempt Abigail Beeman looks at
that angle tonight travelers flow
through Toronto's Pearson Airport one of
four that will remain open to
international flights when new
restrictions come into force you gotta
do proper screening to make sure
everything's straight so you want to
keep sending it back and forth and for
now flights between Canada and the US
are not restricted we've been
collaborating very closely with the
United States but with such a high
number of kovat 19 cases south of the
border British Columbia for one wants a
tougher ban Washington State has seen
the most deaths it's our strong message
that visitors from the United States
not come to British Columbia don't come
at this moment that is the wrong thing
to do that canada-us border in
particular is a lifeline for both of our
countries this is a situation which we
are reviewing constantly in real-time
with a volatile American president who
may not take kindly to a shutdown Ottawa
says Canadian leaders made the decision
on their own and it may change ministers
point to the food supply chain as a
critical thing to protect truck drivers
and others who rely on cross-border life
are also exempt from the 14-day
requirement to self isolate when they
return if we put in measures - for
mandatory self-isolation as many people
have looked for there would need to be
enforcement management measures around
that both by public health and by a
public safety no plans to do that yet
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa nearly
7 million people in the San Francisco
Bay Area are in lockdown u.s. President
Donald Trump did say he would consider a
federal initiative to lock down
so-called hotspots
bringing our Washington bureau chief
Jackson Prosecco so Jackson might this
happen in other areas
well robbing the White House is being
cagey about what exactly might happen in
the coming weeks and months when it
comes to lock downs or travel
restrictions one question that came up
today of course was the border with
Canada after Prime Minister Trudeau's
announcement in that case the president
hinted that they have in fact considered
a lockdown of the Canadian border but he
says it's not something that's on the
table at this exact moment he seemed to
be hinting that the two countries are
simply too closely linked when it comes
to business and trade take a listen we
think about it if we don't have to do it
that'll be good we have very strong
emergency powers when it comes to
something like this both on the southern
and the northern borders and we we are
talking about different things but we'll
see right now we have not decided to do
that and Jackson let's talk about those
concerning concerning comments about
ventilators that Trump made today yeah
this really kind of gives you a sense of
how fractured the American response is
there was a conference call between the
president and all of the state governors
today and on that call the president
told the governor's to go it alone try
and find respirators and other medical
equipments on their own instead of
waiting for a federal response he added
the federal government would have their
backs if needed but that flies in the
face of what we're hearing from local
officials New York's governor today for
example called on the federal government
and the Army Corps of Engineers to start
building hospitals now Trump says he'll
consider it and Robin one more sense of
the patchwork of regulations you talked
about that lock down in San Francisco
for example but generally speaking the
white house is only recommending social
distancing as a recommendation saying no
groups of more than 10 people avoid bars
and avoid non-essential travel those are
recommendations not an order at this
point
Jackson Brasco in Washington despite the
US Federal Reserve's slashing the key
interest rate the markets were still
volatile today the week began with
another huge plunge trading was
temporarily halted this morning on the
Toronto and New York stock exchanges the
third time that has happened in eight
days the TSX closed down more than 1300
points today and nearly 10 percent drop
before ending the day at 12,000 360
points the
Dow Jones plummeted 3,000 points to
close at just over 20,000 points that's
a three year low the situation is
particularly perilous in Italy where for
the second day in a row more than 300
people died in a 24-hour span the
country has confirmed nearly 28,000
cases of Kovan 19 spain is quickly
becoming the next global hot spot more
than 300 people have died in that
country with more than 90 400 people
infected Europe is now the epicenter of
this pandemic and the government's there
are tightening border access the
European Union is planning to restrict
all non-essential travel for foreigners
to its 27 member states although that
ban does not apply to visitors from the
UK
some European countries have already
taken their own stringent steps
barring or limiting entry to
non-citizens as our European chief
crystal commencing reports countries
like France are restricting the
movements of its own people while the UK
is telling Brits to stop all
non-essential contact a plea to UK
citizens do your part and stay home it
looks as though we're now approaching
the fast growth part of the upward curve
and without drastic action cases could
double every five or six days
legislation is not being used instead
the idea is that people will comply
because they see how Europe is
struggling with Kovan 19 thousands have
died in Italy morgues and funeral homes
are overwhelmed at just one Cemetery in
the Lombardy region there were 12
funerals in a six-hour period
Spain is reestablishing land borders as
it fights arise in infections social
distancing is key but the World Health
Organization wants more testing you
cannot fight a fire blindfolded and we
cannot stop this pandemic if we don't
know who is infected we have a simple
message for all countries test test test
crystal commencing Global News London
every year more than 300 thousand
Canadians head south for the winter many
of those so called snowbirds are now
scrambling to get back Ross Lourdes
reports as Cameron Francis arrives home
health inspectors remind him of new
rules that he needs to self isolate for
14 days something he'd rather do in this
corner of the continent Halifax
instead of his adopted home in Los
Angeles I was really scared that I might
be stuck in United States and that the
pandemic might be much more serious and
then I'd be stuck there and unable to
get to my parents my family so I came
back now
in several provinces these inspectors
are being dispatched by provincial
governments tired of waiting for the
federal government to supply them but
Francis suggests Canada is ahead of the
u.s. in taking measures to limit the
spread of the virus I've only seen
information in Canada in Los Angeles's
very little there are similar scenes all
over Canada along with foreign nationals
leaving the country for many passengers
there's less frustration than there is a
sense of relief that they made it home
you know I'm fine we're all fine but we
just wanted to come back into our own
country and if that we were to get sick
or something were to have we'd be here
Malia has been a bit of an inconvenience
but you know I understand and these
things can't be helped and you have to
do what you can to prevent it from
spreading like everyone else
air travelers hope doing their part to
fight the virus will make a difference
Ross Laura Global News halifax stanfield
International Airport classes canceled
during the Cova 19 pandemic coming up
both parents and students are in a bind
you
more than 420 people have tested
positive in Canada for covin 19 here's a
breakdown of where things are at Ontario
confirmed 32 new cases today bringing
the total to 177 there are a hundred and
three cases in BC in Alberta there are
now 74 cases 18 new ones were just
announced and 50 in Quebec there are a
total of 28 cases spread across six
other provinces parents across most of
Canada are now scrambling to find
alternate arrangements for their
children nearly every province and
territory is closing schools and
daycares Alberta and Saskatchewan say
they likely won't reopen until the fall
Heather York's West looks at why the
extended break is necessary
it wasn't the news 18 year old Macy
Fields had hoped for pretty much
instantly started crying it was just
such this scary thought to feel to like
think that school is just cancelled to
faris there as a grade 12 student
canceled classes in Alberta means fields
as high school days are suddenly done
and graduation plans are now up in the
air time is running out to flatten the
curb that's why today we are announcing
that effective immediately we are
suspending all in school class
instruction throughout the province
every student will receive a final grade
based on their current grade and
students will progress to their next
grade level across Saskatchewan students
are now abruptly ending their school
years as well daycares are closing - the
longer term shutdown coming in contrast
to provinces like Ontario where for the
most part classes are suspended for just
a few weeks I'll take my advice off a
chief medical officer if he feels that
is necessary then we'll follow that
advice right now we've closed him till
April the six infectious disease experts
say parents should not bet on schools
and daycares reopening anytime soon two
and a half weeks from now three weeks
from now when everything may be ramping
up again I think we'll see that we're
really in the thick of it and my guess
is that those two week bands are likely
to be extended for parents unable to
work from
the scramble to find childcare is on
Quebec officials are promising to
provide 60,000 daycare spaces for those
who provide essential services but
elsewhere most parents are on their own
back in Calgary Fields knows the demand
for babysitters now will be great and
with school out she's available to lend
a hand
Heather Eurex West level news Calgary up
next experts answer your questions about
the new coronavirus there's so much to
absorb about this new coronavirus about
how to cope and how you can help flatten
the curve and slow the spread many of
you have sent in your questions and our
Jeff simple is trying to answer them by
going to the experts Jeff what are the
biggest concerns from our viewers well
Robin viewers have been emailing in
their coronavirus questions almost by
the minute and one of the most common
kovat 19 concerns take a look at this
viewer email should snowbirds come home
more than 300,000 canadians head south
for the winter every year and are now
wondering what to do while Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau was unequivocal
it's time to come home and medical
experts agree we've seen a lot of
unprecedented things happening such as
border closures and I don't think those
are done the only potential hiccups in
getting home is that as of Wednesday
only four major airports in Canada will
be receiving international passengers
and if you arrive at the border showing
symptoms of kovat night teen you'll be
denied entry oh my goodness if we start
coughing when you get there it's like
what do you do now that's far the
government has been short on details
there will be some assistance there from
the Consular point of view and and
financial assistance Jess another
concern is the testing that's being done
for kovat 19 here's one viewers question
on that my name is Karen Patterson I'm
from Victoria BC my concern is that
there are people coming back from
traveling who won't be tested who could
then be going back to work and childcare
because I run a daycare and then
infecting other people well right now
the answer to the question who gets
tested for kovat 19 partly depends on
the province
you live in anyone showing symptoms who
has travelled abroad recently has been
receiving the test but increasingly
officials in British Columbia and here
in Ontario are focusing less on travel
history and more on the severity of
symptoms because we might be to avoid
testing people who are not sick in order
to reduce crowding in these regional
test centers or crowding in hospitals
anyone who arrives from abroad is being
asked to self isolate for 14 days here's
a question from a viewer who just
arrived back in Canada from California
I'm Debby I'm from New Westminster BC
how will we know when is the appropriate
time to seek somebody from the health
department in other words if you've been
told to self isolate at home and you
develop symptoms when should you seek
medical attention people are having
fevers day after day that are not
resolving if your coffee's getting worse
if you're more and more short of breath
if you're feeling extremely weak like
you're having a hard time getting out of
bed those are all symptoms that are
worrisome but everyone else especially
younger healthier people who develop
mild symptoms are being asked not to go
to the doctor but to stay home to self
isolate stay away from others for 14
days and focus on getting better and in
the vast majority of cases Robin that's
exactly what happens still ahead Canada
looks beyond our borders for lessons on
flattening the curve
[Music]
here's one way to pass the time during
the quarantine in Spain exercise a
fitness instructor led a pop-up workout
from a rooftop and it came back positive
yeah and it sucks that's actor Idris
Elba confirming he has cope at 19 he
says he had no symptoms but was tested
after realizing he was exposed elbow was
recently at an event in London with
Sophia Gregoire Trudeau who also tested
positive for the virus the spread of
Cova 19 has followed a predictable
pattern first a case er - then some more
and suddenly a spike which has led to
the pandemic in more than a hundred
countries Canada is now seeing a sharp
rise but there's still time to bend the
curve back down Eric Swanson explains
Canada is taking dramatic steps because
the spread of the virus is dramatic and
is learning from the experience of other
countries that were inundated sooner
measuring the number of cases day after
day tracks the progress of kovat 19 for
example a steady increase 10 new cases
one day 10 more the next and so on which
show a straight line but real life isn't
like that
in simple terms things are getting worse
when the arc bends upwards 10 new cases
one day 30 the next then 60 and so on
but say the rate is 5 new cases then 10
then holds at 10 new ones and back to 5
there are more new total cases every day
but the rate is slowing the curve starts
to bend downward good news the days
weeks and months ahead will be a test of
our resolve a test of our trust in
science and a test of solidarity China
was the first to confront the outbreak
with a massive surge in cases before
shutting down who Bay Province the virus
spread South Korea was caught by
surprise but aggressively tested and saw
results Italy was slower and it's still
in trouble since mid-february South
Korea has managed to flatten the curve
of new cases over time that's the model
for all countries in Italy cases began
later
but soon surged far surpassing South
Korea Canada has fewer cases and the aim
is to keep it that way but right now the
rate is rising on February 26th Canada
reported 12 cases a week later 34 and
then 118 that was last Wednesday and now
day-by-day rising numbers to 341 on
Sunday and climbing that's why
government industry and Canadians
generally are rapidly changing behavior
to flatten the curve
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this Monday
I'm Robin Gill thank you for watching
good night